as a single mother your value as a woman  is less than somebody who does not have  kids if you're looking for that  long-term relationship which you've said  you are looking for a guy who's like at  your age or older the men who will be  looking for what you're looking for  aren't looking for you they're looking  for women who are much younger than you  who do not have kids do you understand  that well you seem to think that every  woman is exactly the same but i'm not  the same kind of person as the woman  you're talking about i don't have an iq  of a hundred i'm not a [ __ ] i'm fairly  attractive i don't think i'm gonna have  an issue and what i did decide was that  i would rather be by myself my concern  wasn't a hypergamy i'm gonna go find  someone older wiser smarter better  richer and do that i just figured hey  i'll just hunker down and work at least  i'll be happier by myself